Now that we understand reductions,
we're ready to use them to help us prove
decidability and
even more interestingly, undecidability.
Suppose that we have a language
A that's reducible to B, and
let's say that I want to know whether
some string x is in the language A.
Well, if there's a decider for
B then I'm in luck.
I can use the reduction,
which is a computable function,
remember, that takes in one string and
outputs another.
I just need to feed in x and
take the output and
feed that into the decider for B.
If B accepts, then I know that
x is in A and if B rejects,
then I know that it isn't.
This works because by the definition
of a reduction, x is in a, if and
only if, r of x is in b and
by the definition of a decider,
this is true if and
only if, d accepts r of x.
Therefore the output of d
tells me whether x is in a.
If I can figure out whether
a string is in b or not.
Then by the properties of the reduction,
this also let's me figure out whether
the original string x was in A.
That means that we can say that
the composition of the reduction and
the decider for
B is itself a decider for A.
Thus, the fact that A is reducible to
B has four important consequences for
decidability and recognizability.
The easiest to see is that if B is
decidable, then A is also decidable.
As we've seen, we can just compose
the reduction with the decider for B.
The same logic also works if
there's only a recognizer for B.
If we input a string X that is in A,
then R of X will be in B, so
the recognizer will accept.
And if we input a string that is not
in A, then R of X will not be in B, so
the recognizer will not accept.
It might loop.
But we know it won't accept and that's
good enough for our recognizer for A.
The other two consequences are just
the counter positives of these.
If A is undecidable, then this
composition of the reduction and
the decider can't be a decider for A.
Since we're assuming that there is
a reduction, the only possibility
is that the decider for B doesn't exist,
hence B is undecidable.
And the same logic holds for
the unrecognizability of A and B.